hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to affected The Asylum
I'm very very excited to continue
playing this game so no further
introduction required get right into it
so the first part was manner and it was
thoroughly awesome but this part is now
via asylum and I'm gonna try to make
sure that I actually stay in the correct
orientation of where I'm supposed to be
playing but then again I can't promise
anything because I'm probably gonna be
tossed around all over the place which
is awesome so let's continue down so
like most horror game asylums I'm
assuming it's gonna be filled with crazy
people who are going to murder everyone
they see including me
oh no return after this part oh look at
that
animations animations that's really cool
although I don't know that like I've
seen some of the models that are in this
game before so I'm assuming that some of
them are stock it was made on the Unity
engine but this is one of those games
where you're like you know were you like
hey it may be on the Unity engine but
has it actually put some work into it am
I supposed to be looking into these eye
holes is something gonna pop out at me
if I look into the eye holes I hope
something pops out of me hello
someone in there do I see something
moving in there okay I'm gonna assume
that I did not and I'm gonna move up
okay
going into the darkness now my favorite
Oh joyous day Callooh Callay
hello anybody in there no these times
here is gonna be okay this rusty old
sink
me likey Oh what are you more posters on
the walls like the extrange paintings
that I saw everywhere in the manner okay
door ripped off its hinges
strange things flashing lights weird
thumpy thumbs hi yeah what is that what
is that the reason always gyrating his
hips towards me and his hips are kind of
thoroughly detailed did I do a dance who
danced with you I'm gonna move on I'm
gonna move on from that cuz I was
disturbingly close to me as much as I
just enjoy pelvic thrusting I have to go
on to other things yeah okay wheelchair
Simon here bare old door hey who did
that why did you did that there's
nothing on the other side this is gonna
be like penumbra and the big dick worm
is gonna come barreling through the
hallways I would love that
I would love down the big dick worm come
barreling through my hallways if you
know what I mean it's like a game of
whose line I just say dirty things and
if I put if you know what I mean at the
end it's totally okay because it's your
responsibility for coming up with all
the dirtiness okay
hello oh hi hi are you doing
you okay y'alright okay how about you oh
you oh well I have nothing clever to say
except you wanna hang okay I'm not even
go there I make enough bad jokes in it
is I don't need to push my luck why is
this one closed anyway I can open that
one I think I couldn't write this you
drew with someone over there I'm doing
the thing again I'm turning I'm turning
yes someone hello
okay never mind then I'll carry on I
actually when I'm playing this I'd get
into the world nicer looking around the
next oculus rift sensor that's gonna
suck
okay okay
ha ha ha da da da da da da da
hi where'd my flashlight go
hello knock knock anybody home oh it's
blackness a red flag oh good there's my
last night what it's all flickering
flugel oh good
I'm just waiting for one of these to fly
open and something to scare me hi hello
friend you wanna know what whatever hi
hi hi hi hi hi nice butt smack mmm oh
one of these doors open okay that's what
that was
okay what what what what oh what oh I
see something over there
anyway I think I was on the train of
thought but I got a little distracted
the next oculus rift is actually gonna
have sensors on the good god is it dark
in here
okay can't go that way explosive barrel
blocking my path can't go that way is
gurney gonna have sensors on the actual
device oh it's that can track your head
location so that when you move like this
the camera will actually move side to
side and forward and backwards what is
that what is that that's like a double
barrel two barrel Braille Braille ignore
me my brains not functioning at 100%
hello I just never is really
this conflicting information on whether
the thing about it you only use a third
of your brain oh hi
no I think that was a halflife noise I
recognize that hello
someone being murdered brutally over
here okay I'm just checking all these
doors just in case cuz you never know
oh look someone's been murdered brewed
oh my god did your face get ripped off
oh this is your last chance to turn back
okay I was gonna turn back where you run
away from me
yeah I'm pretty scary don't man me
hey buddy hey y'alright need some water
you okay
you'll be okay it's rub some dirt in it
walk it off oh I'm actually I'm supposed
to turn back okay well I seem to have
gotten some common sense all of a sudden
let me just think about what I'm gonna
do and then turn back and run away at
full speed oh now there's a gurney over
there good
anybody somebody want to tango with me
Oh
well someone's having a party over there
wouldn't mind going towards the happy
fun times there's being had uh-huh
did I just see something it was that
actually something did I catch okay
nevermind getting paranoid now darkness
darkness is getting to me where could it
have gone
no hello Dan they missed an opportunity
all these doors with little eye holes
and they didn't actually put anything to
scare me with okay flashing light over
there door closed over there nothing
over here I'm gonna assume that there's
nothing unless the one door I didn't
check actually had something in it which
it might have or had had blue moon hey
let's go come on bring it on I'm ready
for you oh good going down to the deep
dark darkness that way we can find our
friends we're gonna murder us dead
oh this is where the happy fun party is
hey Mark Myers here ready to have some
fun I don't think it's the party that I
wanted to go to photo hmm okay party's
over
we're buddy go home hey hey buddy
hey buddy you're still alive in there
hey you still live finally someone else
who's alive is you me good lordy Lou
who's there huh ha hey thanks come back
hey you stop that over there hey cut
that out
man you gotta admit that they actually
put in animations and stuff into this
game there was a lot of work put into
this really really well done I applaud
their efforts so I gotta kind of come
out busted
you dick yeah yeah thumbs up all you
want you to get me loser haha what a
ugly loser you are moving on anybody in
here
anybody in here new I will admit that
when I'm playing this game the one flaw
that I could say out of it is that it's
more of a sideshow of Horrors as opposed
to like uh something that could actually
be a threat to me it is quite scary but
it's more like haunted house scary
you're walking through it and oh there's
that scare oh there's that scare yay
what what are you crying about your big
baby your big bubble blowing baby what
monsters gonna get you all right you
could you just keep crying down there
I'm gonna move on and face all
what the hell wait a minute oh I know
that
do-do-do-do-do that's the mo outlast
that isn't that is the guys without last
that's cool it's towards the end there
yeah I recognize it anywhere are some of
these Asylum guys from a list well
that's cool I don't know how they got
the battle to it but I must not have
been mapped on an engine was where
engine was uh-oh okay go hi is there an
escape going on it wouldn't make sense
if I'm in an asylum because that kind of
was our last whole deal maybe they just
got Sally peep what does that say tan T
turn back I've already gone this far why
would I turn back cuz I'm gonna pop out
of me
No
No is someone there
hello okay okay good ever so I'm gonna
pop out of me oh you know I'm very
dangerous when I get back to new a
corner I'm like a wild animal Pryor oh
hey hey hey hey hey
Oh Jimmy oh hi you look friendly and
twitchy can I help you with something
can I help you what are you oh good hi
did you did you uh state your intention
did you did you possibly just you
possibly we could you possibly be oh
okay oh okay listen oh okay no thank you
Oh
haha well Leo I knew I knew I knew I
knew I knew it I knew something Oh
everything is a crooked wait where am I
looking okay I'm looking straight on but
everything's slightly crooked okay
anyway oh man
even though it is kind of like going
through a haunted house going through a
haunted house is still fun
like I would ha I still highly recommend
this because they did a lot of really
cool work with it like they imported
some models from outlast you know the
high quality models that were in that
game they did like I'm pretty sure there
was some custom animations going on I
thought those Asylum guys look a little
familiar but they didn't really know
from where but I think they were also
from us um outlast maybe they got some
animation from outlast - and I'm giving
them too much credit but either way for
a free game this has some amazing work
put into it and I think they have a lot
of potential so check out their website
and there's still is one more part of
this amazing or oculus rift game so stay
tuned for that tomorrow thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
more videos and I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
Oh
Jesus
haha
Kludd
there's another dead body
so headless